[Music]
brian is in cleveland ohio
hi brian how are you dave and chris how
are you guys
great man how can we help good good so
uh first off i just want to thank the
both of you i listen to your guys show
all the time
my wife and i started our debt free
journey uh last november
cool we paid almost uh twenty thousand
dollars off way to go
um really excited yes thank you so my
call
actually isn't about me um my parents uh
i'm really emotional about this i
apologize uh okay
started i started my debt free journey
because of them um
they've they've struggled with money
they've always been there for us they're
wonderful people
um so they've they've struggled with
money um
they were heading into retirement here
um in the next couple months
with a lot of debt um mortgage was 80
000
uh and i think the same amount in credit
card or vehicle debt
well we found out yesterday that they
actually just won
a lottery here they won 340 000
um i want to make sure
that i mean i want to help guide them
the way you guys have kind of helped me
on what they should do with their
finances um they're
going to pay off all their debt i just
didn't know what you would recommend
they do with any remaining money as far
as investments
or savings and stuff along those lines
so
well 340 000 is wonderful and if you
send me a check for that i'll cash it
okay absolutely but let me tell you what
happens with people
that don't have any money that are
broken in debt and they win 340 000
their brain tells them it's 34 million
right and i i don't want to sound
snobbish
but it's not that much money
because they can screw this up real easy
okay
it's not so much money that they don't
need to
become very very serious about the
subject of money
because it's still they still have a lot
of problems
this does not set them up for retirement
it helps
right but it doesn't set them up and so
the first thing i would coach you to
tell them
is to try to help them get their head
around the emotions of
this is not that much money so i still
need to learn to behave
yep okay because if they don't
it's going to just evaporate and they're
going to be in in i'll let me tell you
seven years they'll be sitting right
where they are today
if they do not change their mentality
about money
because their money problems are
symptoms of their behaviors
the behaviors are the core problem so
that's not to shame them or beat them up
when i went broke it was because my
behaviors
made me go broke i did stupid butt stuff
and it always knocks you upside the head
you know what i'm saying
only does it and they have been and
they've been doing this their whole
lives not because they're bad people
they're wonderful people
they just suck at money yeah okay so i
don't want them to think this
heals that yeah that's what i want to
break
big deal because if we can get inside
their psyches and
lovingly let them admit out loud and
admit
down in their guts that this is not this
much money but if i play my cards right
this could be the thing that's going to
make it okay
even though i've messed up up until this
point so
first thing is yeah we're going to get
out of debt then we're going to do some
investing and chris can walk you through
that
and then we're going to put them into
ramsey plus where they go through
financial peace university i'll pay for
it
so they just hit the lottery again
because that's worth more than 340 000
dollars by the way
yeah because over the scope of their
life the mo when they change their
behaviors they're gonna have a lot more
than 340 000
even though they're approaching
retirement age yep and brian i have
worked with people
i've been with dave 15 years now um i've
worked with people that have hit the
lottery
much larger dollar amounts uh but i'm
going to tell you the story of the
people that do it well
are the people that get connected they
understand the game plan and they start
to walk through the baby steps
rather quickly because they have that
but
here's the ones that didn't do it well
the ones that as they've talked about
thought that this was enough to set them
up
they didn't change their habits and
these are the people within two and a
half years
have gone back into debt gambling or
doing something to reach for that other
savior
and so i would tell you about it worked
lunch and it'll work again it'll happen
again so
uh brian you can guide them but you
can't be that person
okay you can guide them but ultimately
how they choose to handle it
you would i'd get them connected with
some people that are really going to
love on them yeah and
walk with them but but that can't be you
so let's let's do
a couple things one is we'll put them
into financial peace university and
ramsey plus i'll pay for it for a year
so that they can have the chance at this
turning their lives around and it can be
a blessing in that regard
if they do not change their habits the
money is going to be wasted and so will
this effort
so this is this is their shot this is
their opportunity
to reset okay and you've got to get that
through to them
then the second thing is jump on as
chris said let's get somebody in their
corner jump on it
uh at daveramsey.com click smart vester
and then when all the debts paid off we
got the emergency fund set aside
whatever's left let's throw that towards
investments
and i would hold out three or four
thousand dollars to blow and enjoy
but not thirty thousand dollars it's not
that much money
so you pay off the house you'll be back
in debt you pay off the cars you'll be
back in debt you do all this you'll be
back in debt if you don't get on a
budget
have your emergency fund and live on
less than you make the rest
of your freaking lives and then you're
they're going to have a lot more than
340 000 a decade from now they really
will and brian also reach out to one of
our tax eops
they need to go ahead and get a full
view of exactly how this is going to
impact their taxes
on a federal and a state level probably
going to take half of it you're going to
hit them
it's going to get hit there may not be
any money left after you pay off the
debt and pay the taxes
it really may not but either way as dave
said it can be a blessing or a curse it
just depends on
how they view it and what they do moving
forward my friend
thank you for calling us yeah
intentionality intentional